[Music]
tis the season to be queer yeah there's
a lot to be thankful for this holiday
season and something I'm thankful for
are some touching and hilarious holiday
films with lgbtq Plus storylines movies
like happiest season come with me to my
parents house for Christmas
Abby you and Harper have a perfect
relationship she is my person and I
really want everyone to know that with
an All-Star cast the film follows the
story of a woman's plans to propose to
her girlfriend while at her family's
holiday party except she discovers her
partner hasn't come out to her
conservative parents yet there's
something that we should talk about do
you remember when I came out to my
parents that's not entirely accurate
in 2020 star Kristen Stewart told ET
Canada about the history being made with
the film The More I actually think about
it as a fact the more surprising it is
that
um this is technically the first gay
Christmas rom-com backed by a studio
um so that like alone was exciting for
me because uh you know it's really
important to broaden perspectives and
hear from everyone and like I can't
believe that we're so late to the game
but that's how it goes I feel so lucky
to be talking about something like this
right now I love Kristen in this film
another movie to make your spirits
bright single all the way Netflix's
first gay holiday film the movie follows
a single man who convinces his best
friend to pretend to be his boyfriend
when heading home for the holidays
I think you should come home with me you
can pretend we fell in love after all
these years but it'd be so easy my
family already asked why we're not just
together all right thank you thank you
thank you but this film is so pure so
full of love so full of joy it means a
lot to me especially I'm a young black
man you know coming from that area and
to see representation where it isn't
negative you can be yourself there is
acceptance out there it means the world
to me hey co-star Jennifer Coolidge gave
us the gift of her advice on how singles
can grab attention on Grindr I suggest
um putting an animal in the shot an
animal so you wouldn't say like bare
chest or like a koi pose I just feel
like when you put the animal in with
like one of these hot guys put their dog
in whatever I don't know why you can
just get so many more hits the gays just
know how to do stuff for some reason
you're always obsessed with me
can confirm now in 2020 Hallmark's first
movie to prominently feature a same-sex
couple was released the Christmas house
follows a couple who invite their two
adult sons to come back for Christmas
and recreate a family tradition thank
you Jake
Have I Told You Lately you're my
favorite son-in-law you might be your
favorite son period if you're going to
be this peppy for the first time the
little Jonathan's the little James's and
you know out there who are watching it
are able to see themselves in a movie
and they and maybe for the first time at
Christmas they feel seen and they feel a
little less scared about the future he's
right that's the power of representation
other films to get you warm and fuzzy
lifetimes the Christmas setup the first
lgbtq plus themed holiday film ever
broadcast by LifeTime I don't have to
ask Santa for anything this year I
already got it Netflix's Let It Snow
that girl and I
kind of had like a thing
[Music]
you hooked up yeah but I don't know it
was more than that finally I have to
give a shout out to the Family Stone
which has this powerful scene we didn't
you didn't really hope for gay children
did you
I just think any parent would want a
normal child God damn you okay
just for the child's sake just to make
it easier for the child that's enough
I've
woof it gets me every time so what's
your favorite lgbtq plus holiday film
let me know in the comments below
[Music]
[Laughter]